information tonight about a reported
multi-million dollar ice plan to provide
migrant families with hotel rooms free
health screenings
and coronavirus tests among other
amenities before releasing them after 72
hours
spring in texas lieutenant governor dan
patrick to discuss the ongoing border
crisis
as the immigration numbers continue to
swell good to be back sir
good to be with you shannon i want to
play something i don't know if you heard
it earlier in the show but we have a
sound bite from congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez
and the terminology that's been used
about the border and what's happening
here's what she says
i want to say what about the surge first
of all
just gut check stop anyone who's using
the term
surge around you consciously
is trying to invoke a militaristic frame
this is not a surge these are children
and they are not insurgents and we are
not being
invaded there's been a lot made about
the semantics about this is it a crisis
is it a challenge the surge is not a
surge just give us the lowdown about
what's actually happening at the border
shannon the more i hear her speak the
more i realize she's really clueless
about
what's going on in the world she's
surely clueless about what's happening
on the
border it is a surge we're
almost double the number of people that
we were apprehending just a couple of
months ago
in just this month we apprehended 21 000
people in the third week of march and 27
000 people
the last week and by the way 75 percent
roughly of those that we apprehend
shannon are otms
other than from mexico so they're from
all over central
south america and around the world what
aoc
says continues to be idiotic and
irresponsible
we had a texas ranger save a baby that
was thrown in the river
just recently we had a child drowned in
the river
we have over ten thousand overflowing in
various bases
federal facilities and some private
facilities that the federal government
is taking over
aoc if she isn't idiotic in what she
says
then she knows better and is lying to
the american people about what she says
i'm fed up quite frankly shannon with
all of these people in washington who
have no idea what's happening on the
border
or they know and they're just lying to
the american public the biden
administration
must know he's in contact with his
cabinet members his agency officials
that oversee
this and it is a tragedy what's
happening
she's been there previously i mean she
hasn't been there this time around so
clearly she has to have some concept of
what's happening
we've heard from democrats and
republicans there at the border i keep
thinking of congressman henry cuellar a
democrat there from texas
this is impacting him and his
constituents he is well aware of the
situation he was the first one to
release pictures from inside so there's
bipartisan objection
there's bipartisan concern about these
people as human beings
that has bubbled up to the bind
administration there can be no doubt
about that
senator lindsey graham when he was there
last weekend said or last week said
he talked to a top border official who
told him they had briefed the biden
transition team who had asked what will
happen if we reverse some of these trump
policies
he says uh senator graham that they were
told this is exactly what would happen
and he's now looking for answers about
who in washington was informed about
this and why they proceeded anyway
you know kevin cork reported a bit
earlier about the washington post
is talking about that ice is going to
put thousands of people
tens of millions of dollars to house
them in hotels um to get them testing
which is good
everybody agrees they should have cova
testing they should have health care
if they're in need when they show up but
where do we go from here there seems to
be no appetite whether republicans or
democrats are in charge of washington
for getting this resolved in some more
permanent substantive way
well shannon when president trump uh was
in
office he had really solved this problem
not totally you're never going to
end a 100 of people crossing the border
illegally
but he had made those agreements with
the mexican president
they put troops on the border they also
kept everyone who was seeking asylum
in mexico so they could come here
orderly when their time was certain
since biden came in and you know i
thought obama was bad on the border
biden has has made obama look like a
[ __ ] in terms of
his border policy biden either
is being lied to by his cabinet
officials
either he knows the truth and is lying
to the american public
because it is so obvious to see
even people around the country who do
not live in texas who haven't been to
the border can watch the videos
the limited videos and the limited
photographs but it we are overrun
america is under siege i don't care what
aoc says
it is an invasion of people from around
the world coming here it is a surge aoc
coming here we are up 100 over 2020 at
this
period of time with families here we're
up almost 180 percent
of unaccompanied minors here what are we
going to do in america with all of these
children
and the hotel package they put together
comes out to thousands and thousands of
dollars
per illegal immigrant they're flying
them all over the country you heard
everything they're getting when they
come here and in addition to that
my guess is what will come with their
hotel package is
fast express lane citizenship before the
2024 elections
and they'll be some of those folks that
they want to legalize for vote
harvesting
this is about the democrats taking power
permanently in this country on the backs
of these people who will they
they will sign up and give them
citizenship and voter registration
and that's what this is all about it it
how can you deny it
at this point i don't mean you
personally how can they deny because you
cannot make an excuse
for kids drowning in the river for our
our state and our country being overrun
when it's there in plain daylight plain
to see and there are people
there are people who are coyotes and
smugglers who are clearly feeding them
messages that if they can just get here
their life will have a lot more promise
and that's got to be an appealing
message for people who are in dire
straits but again these are human beings
and we have to figure this out
lieutenant governor thank you for coming
in yes shannon thank you